comme toutes les maladies génétiques
sont des maladies rares faut le savoir
le seuil les myopathies la mucoviscidose
ou les leucodystrophies sont des
maladies rares j'allais dire
heureusement mais malheureusement pour
ceux qui sont concernés qui attaquent la
gaine des nerfs qu'on appelle la méline
et un r c'est un petit peu comme un fil
électrique vous enlever un ici devant
vous avec une belle gueule bleus cette
gaine c'est ce qu'on appelle la myéline
autour d'une ère et c'est ce qui permet
la conduction nerveuse donc les messages
nerveux ne peuvent pas c'est que si
cette gaine est intacte malheureusement
dans les leucodystrophies vous voyez il
ya des petits trous dans la gaine la
gaine est abîmée alors soit ça arrive
dès la naissance et à dire que l'enfant
dès la naissance
malheureusement manque de myéline donc
il ya des trous où il n'a pas et
quelquefois même assez souvent ça peut
arriver pendant l'enfance voire même à
l'âge adulte la gaine est intact mais
malheureusement elles dégénèrent et ça
entraîne vous le voyez ici sur la droite
énormément de perturbation dans toutes
les grandes fonctions vitales la vue
l'ouïe la mémoire la parole la
locomotion bien sûr sont des maladies
donc extrêmement lourdes extrêmement
grave et je me suis rendu compte en 1990
qu'on était très peu nombreux pour
partager ça néanmoins je me suis dit que
la seule chose que je pouvais faire
c'était essayer de rassembler des
familles autour de moi le plus possible
c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à faire en me disant que face à
un problème aussi lourd et sans
finalement solution on avait au moins
quelque chose c'est d'être nos envies
d'être tout on forme de pouvoir se
réunir et c'est de voir comment ensemble
on pourrait réagir et se crée battre et
combattre cette maladie
c'est ce qu'on a fait très très vite
d'abord à une petite poignée de familles
surtout lorraine et ensuite vous voyez
en 1994 la slide de droite déjà avec un
peu plus de familles c'est la première
fois qu'on se réunit vraiment
tous ensemble à center parc c'est
d'ailleurs devenu une tradition chaque
année on a ce grand rendez vous là on
était une grosse poignée je dirais
peut-être une cinquantaine de personnes
l'année dernière on était plus de 800 et
c'est un rendez vous annuel que les
familles attendent aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup d'impatience forme fort de ce
rassemblement on a compris au moins une
chose c'est qu'on était capables
ensemble de faire quelque chose de
positif de cette de ce problème et
d'essayer de le dépasser
on a on s'est rendu compte aussi qu'on
avait un problème qui dépassait
largement les intérêts particuliers ça
ça me paraît très important et on va
revenir là dessus parce que si vous
voulez dans tout regroupement humain
lorsqu'il s'agit de viser un objectif
aussi aussi utile ou si important que
éradiquer de maladie encore faut-il
qu'on soit au clair sur le fait que
c'était bien l'objectif mais pas des
objectifs connaît pas d objectifs
parallèles avec des intérêts
particuliers qui viennent se mêler mais
qui finalement contrarier un petit peu
l'objectif principal est donc nous
sommes dit qu'il fallait absolument
qu'on alerte l'opinion qu'on soit plus
nombreux parce qu'une maladie génétique
par définition est rare donc il fallait
absolument qu'on fasse partager ce
problème à beaucoup d'autres personnes
et on s'est dit que le plus simple était
d'aller chercher des personnalités de
premier plan qui soit un petit peu comme
des spots comme les comme des sunlights
comme des porte drapeaux qui pourrait
éclairer notre combat c'est ce qu'on a
fait vous voyez on n'a pas traîné pour
d'abord faire comme beaucoup
d'associations font participer à fort
boyard des 95 ensuite et main pour
profiter d'opportunités comme la venue
de l'équipe de france de basket à nancy
par exemple et prendre des clichés avec
elles et leur expliquer notre problème
pour profiter aussi d'une opportunité
avec cantonales pour lancer une campagne
nationale
nez rouge etc et cetera mettre le logo
des là sur une la coque d'un bateau etc
tout ça vous pouvez vous pas qu'on peut
paraître la communication futile mais en
fait pour nous c'était essentiel c'était
le seul moyen de d'élargir on va dire le
socle de gens qui pourraient se sentir
concernés par notre problème et on a
continué comme ça tout au long de ces
années y compris vous voyez en 81
18 le coup d'envoi d'un match de
football au stade de france c'était
après la coupe du monde de 98 donc et
c'est deschamps qui était capitaine à
l'époque de cette belle équipe qui nous
a fait gagner
tout ça pour vous dire que pour nous la
communication était essentielle et à
chaque fois vous voyez des enfants de
l'association pas des figurants des
enfants l'association
le plus souvent ces enfants sont encore
en bonne santé mais ils sont porteurs
comme l'était mon fils de cette maladie
génétique extrêmement grave
et quand je dis que les enfants ont sont
une force y compris les enfants malades
ou que les parents eux mêmes ont cette
force cette énergie décuplée
c'est pas un vain mot c'est même ça qui
nous a permis de décoller j'allais dire
regardez cet enfant qui est sur la
droite qui s'appelle jérémy et c'est
cette photo-là qui a marqué les esprits
l'esprit de plein de plein de
personnalité mais en particulier de
florent pagny et qui a à partir de ceux
de cette photo et du message de la
moment bien sûr jeté un peu comme une
bouteille à la mer décidé de s'engager
auto et avec avec nous et 2000 et une
année évidemment un peu particulière
pour nous puisque c'est l'arrivée
également d'une personnalité de premier
plan
premier plan zinédine zidane bon là
encore le personnage lui-même est
intéressant mais surtout il nous apporte
encore une fois un éclairage sur le
combat des parents
exceptionnelle il nous il ramène avec
lui le monde du foot bien sûr le monde
du sport en général et même au delà
puisque tous les médias évidemment lui
courent après et donc nous on récupère
une partie de cet intérêt pour le
personnage on le récupère une partie de
l'intérêt des médias faut mener notre
combat on n'oublie pas notre combat ont
fait pas dans la paille est même si ça
donne l'impression là c'est pas du tout
le but d'une association de parents
comme la nôtre et vous voyez qu'on a
fait faire à à zizou plein de choses
qu'il n'aurait jamais voulu faire dans
un autre contexte
il l'a vraiment fait pour est là parce
qu'il déteste vous le savez tous la
télévision c'est sa première émission de
télévision qui a duré plus de deux
heures qu'il a accepté de faire pour le
bien est là et c'est vrai aussi pour ce
match de foot là vous voyez où deux
personnages sont en jaune lui a
l'habitude d'être sur le terrain de
football mais je peux vous dire que
pour pagny c'était son premier et son
dernier match de foot d'ailleurs on voit
bien qu'il n'est pas très à l'aise plus
de belles rencontres comme celle que
vous avez sous les yeux entre zidane et
l'abbé pierre et tout ça nous a permis à
la fois fier effectivement gagné en
notoriété
c'était important et surtout de
commencer à installer notre propre
projet notre propre concept celui sur
lequel on allait pouvoir s'appuyer pour
les années futures et développé à notre
rythme et donc on a lancé une campagne
qui s'appelle mets tes baskets et bats
la maladie qu'on a démarré au collège ne
chope à nancy qui est à moins d'un
kilomètre d'ici et qu'on a petit à petit
développé dans toutes les académies et
depuis 22 ans dans l'école et on s'est
dit que puisqu'on s'adressait aux
enfants des écoles nous en font bien
portants on leur demande et puis ce
qu'ils avaient eu le loisir d'aller à
l'école une chance incroyable
le loisir d'utiliser leurs baskets pour
faire du sport est bien de pour sacrer
une journée à des enfants comme eux le
même du même âge que tu malheureusement
ne pouvait pas aller à l'école qui
malheureusement ne pouvait pas usé leurs
baskets et c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
beaucoup de satisfaction pour les
parents que nous sommes puisque 22 ans
après plus de 4 millions d'élèves se
sont engagés dans cette campagne 30
académie mais ça c'est pas c'est pas
normal et plus de 28 millions d'euros
collectés et ça c'est le nerf de la
guerre pour les actions que on avait
nous a développé je n'oublie pas mais je
termine quand même dès cette première
partie par le fait qu' on a on
s'adresser ensuite au monde de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire finalement les
parents de ces enfants est encore une
fois sur un concept un petit peu
différent mais l'idée quand même de se
mobiliser dans une activité sportive
les enfants courent beaucoup aux adultes
on leur demande simplement de marcher
mais de compter leurs pas et chaque pas
est traduit en dons pour l'association
ela et vous voyez que en cinq ans on a
déjà mobilisé 70 mille collaborateurs
pour plus de 200 entreprises et 1
million 700 mille euros un peu plus a
été ou déjà été collectés tout ça nous
permet de quoi tout ça nous permet
d'avancer dans nos objectifs on les
oublie pas le premier c'était de
sensibiliser on le fait chaque année
vous voyez au travers des événements
mais on le fait aussi au travers du
soutien des familles
parce que on le sait on le sait on est
parent nous mêmes on sait très bien que
les enfants malades d'aujourd'hui
peu d'entre eux malheureusement peu
d'entre eux pourront profiter des
bénéfices de la recherche et le deuxième
pilier deuxième objectif de
l'association est bien pour ces familles
pour toutes les familles de
l'association
on met au point et on met à leur
disposition d'abord un soutien humain
avec toute une équipe de permanente
dédiée à lörrach on à l'accompagnement
du quotidien on va dire que ce soit un
médecin une psychologue une assistante
sociale
on apporte des soutiens directs des
soutien financier direct parce qu'on
croit toujours que la sécu paye tout
mais c'est pas vrai je peux vous dire
que lorsqu un handicap ce un handicap
important s'installe dans une famille et
bien le coup du handicap est très
important donc nous on compense on
essaie de compenser ce handicap en
important des aides directes sur
l'aménagement d'un d'une salle de bains
ou même d'une maison totalement ou d'un
véhicule adapté pour transporter
fauteuil roulant par exemple et ça
représente quand même un million d'euros
un peu plus d'un million d'euros l'an
dernier et enfin un soutien pour le
répit je vous le dis on organise des
grands rassemblements à center parc mais
pas seulement on fait des plus petits
rassemblements ont propres ou proposent
même des enfin des sorties des sorties
dans des concerts ou des sorties au
théâtre pour les familles d'associations
au coup par coup grâce d'ailleurs à des
places qui sont offerts par nos autres
par un ceux qui font de ceux qui sont
comédiens ou ceux qui sont chanteurs
deuxième objectif de l'association ela
c'est le soutien à la recherche ce même
le pilier central en tout cas celui dans
lequel on dépense nous le plus de la
part de budget la recherche est
structuré maintenant au niveau
international chaque année on lance un
appel d'offres un appel à projets donc
internationale et aux finances ces
projets en fonction de leurs intérêts
une chose importante parce que
l'association ela est une association de
parents concernés ce ne sont pas les
scientifiques qui décident du choix
l'orientation des programmes même si on
est bien dans le domaine scientifique
ce sont les parents eux mêmes c'est nous
qui définissons l'orientation des
programmes de recherche
on peut comprendre assez facilement
les scientifiques on en a besoin je suis
pas en train de dire qu'on est au
contraire on les aime on les chouchoute
et on les accompagne
mais évidemment les scientifiques sont
intéressés par le sujet de recherche pas
forcément par tout de suite un essai
clinique ou ou tout de suite une
application très direct ou au confort de
nos enfants malades
c'est pour ça qu'on fait nous l'effort
de orienté ce programme pour qu'ils
aillent dans une direction la plus
appliquée possible pour qu'enfin on
puisse améliorer le sort des enfants
malades
et ça c'est très important on lance
également parallèlement des programmes
on va dire stratégiques par exemple l'an
dernier on a inauguré ici à nancy au chu
nancy une biobanque c'est à dire un
endroit où on met des échantillons de
tissus humains
donc ils vont procéder à cette bio
banque à nancy au chu de nancy va
concentrer tous les tissus prélèvement
des différents enfants de toute la
france et même au delà et vont pouvoir
être tracé vont pouvoir évidemment
servir à des objets de recherche c'est
un programme quand même qui a coûté à
l'association 2 millions auto million
trois cent mille euros
et c'est un partenariat avec le chu de
nancy donc voilà un exemple de projet
stratégique pour nous qui va nous
permettre dans la durée des beaucoup
plus efficace dans la recherche
disons plus fondamental pour le coup sur
les leucodystrophies
et le troisième point le troisième point
que je voulais vous indiquez c'est le
lancement de nouveaux programmes qui
sont dès les essais cliniques cette fois
il n'y a pas tant que ça mais quand même
hélas aujourd'hui capable de d'organiser
et de dettes le promoteur d'un essai
clinique par exemple l'an dernier on a
lancé un essai clinique pour tester une
nouvelle molécule et on l'a testé et on
l'a lancée sur des formes adultes de la
maladie dans trois centres européens
un pari un en allemagne une autre à
barcelone
donc vous voyez qu'une association de
parents avec la force des parents peu un
moment donné investir tous les nids tous
les champs qui sont utiles pour faire
avancer notre problème depuis dont 92
470 programme de recherche ont pu être
financés
240 millions d'euros ou peut être
consacrés à cette recherche
293 articles scientifiques ont pu être
publiées grâce encore une fois au
programme que nous avons financé et
parmi ces pour ceux qui s'intéressent à
l'aspect scientifique parmi ces
programmes paris pardon ses publications
il y à des applications par exemple très
prestigieuse dans silent ou donateurs et
même autour d'une année c'est quinine
justement de thérapie génique sur des
enfants atteints de leucodystrophie cinq
enfants au départ et parmi ses cinq
enfants aujourd'hui la mallette pour la
maladie pour eux est stabilisé c'est
grâce donc encore une fois au moyen de
l'association ela est donc grâce
évidemment la générosité de ses
donateurs
c'est quand même ça semble peu cinq
enfants
mais c'est un essai quand même hyper
important pour le monde pour la
recherche médicale
parce que si on est capable de réparer
ou de stabiliser ou d'empêcher le
développement du mali ni d'une maladie
neurologique chez l'enfant
on peut à partir de la réparer soigner
ou guérir ou stopper des maladies
neurologiques beaucoup plus fréquentes
je pense notamment à la sclérose en
plaques par exemple ou à d'autres
maladies encore dont vous voyez que
c'est et c'est là ont l'air de rien mais
c'est un petit peu la leucodystrophie
c'est un petit peu le prototype de la
formule 1 ont fait passer dans cette
formule 1 énormément de progrès
de progrès ne serait-ce dans le domaine
de la sécurité pour les voitures de
monsieur tout le monde
eh ben c'est un petit peu pareil dans la
recherche ou les pauses profite pour
ensuite des progrès dans des maladies
beaucoup plus fréquentes
voilà les troisième et dernier objectif
important est majeur pour nous c'est de
développement de l'action à
l'international encore une fois pas pour
devenir une multinationale vous allez
comprendre que c'est pas le but de
l'association pas du tout mais pour
rassembler des familles bien au delà
d'un simple pays c'est pas suffisant
pour mener des recherches parce que pour
mener une recherche qui soit
statistiquement efficace et bien il vous
faut le plus de patients possible et
donc vous êtes obligés d'aller les
chercher là où ils sont dans d'autres
pays européens et donc nous sommes nous
avons créé des sur le modèle de
l'association ela en france donc d'autre
modèle associatif avec le droit local
dans huit autres pays qui s'affiche donc
devant vous et c'est aussi le moyen de
permettre de mettre en moins de mettre
en commun justement des moyens puisque
la recherche demande de plus en plus
d'argent
surtout lorsqu'on a bandé essais
cliniques et donc les allemands les
belges les espagnols et c'est bien
mettre en commun ses moyens encore une
fois réunis par des parents comme je
suis par des parents j'insiste par des
familles et nous avons créé l'an dernier
un une structure internationale et la
internationale que j'ai l'honneur de
présider aujourd'hui et qui en fait
pilote la recherche à l'échelon
international sur les leucodystrophies
longtemps et accompagne le développement
de chaque antenne nationale dans les
pays qui s'affiche devant vous donc j'ai
l'occasion moi de me déplacer beaucoup
en ce moment justement pourra les
accompagner toutes ses antennes à se
développer et à dépasser la france parce
que notre objectif n'est pas de rester
les meilleurs ou les plus forts notre
objectif c'est que l'on soit tous
ensemble très très fort 23 ans d'action
c'est ben 10 millions d'euros un peu
plus même dans l'accompagnement des
familles c'est quatre fois plus pour le
financement de la recherche ça vous
étonne pas c'est là nous en sommes fiers
plus de 90% des
budget chaque année qui est consacré aux
missions sociales et essai et safed et
là le premier financeur privé de la
recherche médicale pour finalement une
petite association en nombre puisque ne
compte que 1200 adhérents payants et
c'est pas l'adhésion qui est un frein à
la dame au nombre d'adhérents puisque
l'adhésion est à 9 euros voyez que c'est
pas vraiment le problème est là en
conclusion si on voulait résumer les
peut-être les caractères les critères
les qualités qui font qu' il a pu se
développer comme elle a pu le faire je
suis pas en train de dire que là elle
est la première association non pas du
tout et bien sûr les leucodystrophies
sans doute quand même c'est d'abord la
force des premiers concernés c'est à
dire les parents que je représente
aujourd'hui les enfants vous avez vu que
les enfants aussi où on se ce pouvoir de
convaincre rien car regard peut
convaincre je peux vous dire que zizou
avec son petit copain yann c'est une
histoire forte c'est pas juste une
rencontre comme ça à la débotté donc
c'est important c'est cette force là qui
nous a permis nous de d'avoir nos
premiers résultats et d'accompagner les
familles au mieux je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on retrouve dans d'autres groupes
humains une telle énergie une telle
volonté d'atteindre un but bien précis
sans se laisser polluer par je sais pas
moi guerre interne des problèmes de
personnes des intérêts particuliers
notre seul intérêt c'est de mettre la
clé sous la porte le plus vite possible
le plus vite possible vous allez me dire
il y fait rigoler c'est 23 ans qu'il est
là baril parce que le problème n'est pas
réglé autrement ou mettraient la clef
sous la porte et de moi je serai le plus
heureux des hommes
j'ai pas besoin de della pour vivre loin
de là et donc et donc on n'a pas encore
mis mon va la mettre j'espère le plus
vite possible et ça sera d'autant plus
vite que les soutiens seront nombreux
donc thomas si vous entendez parler la
payer une oreille attentive et n'hésitez
pas à rentrer dans la danse
voilà merci pour votre attention